solo los vehículos de los militares y de
los voluntarios transitan por bakmut que
desde hace meses es el gran objetivo de
las fuerzas de Moscú
dimi privilegia la situación local de
los servicios de emergencia de Ucrania
hoy reubicados en una localidad cercana
esta mañana han venido hasta backmuk
respondiendo al llamado de un hombre
mayor enfermo de cáncer que ha pedido
ser evacuado de la ciudad
todo lo que podamos hacer de nuestro
lado lo hacemos pero todo el mundo tiene
una opinión propia sobre lo que hay que
hacer en estos momentos nosotros no
estamos en condiciones de decirles Cómo
actuar
al menos 5000 personas de los 60.000 que
habitaban en la ciudad se han negado a
partir se han quedado a pesar de la
destrucción y de que la batalla cada vez
está cerca
fuimos atacados de nuevo por eso tenemos
que vivir en el sótano porque las piezas
de los cohetes y proyectiles vuelan
alrededor
pero como muchos vladimirrense dice que
se queda porque no tiene dinero y jugar
a donde ir y es que aquí cada uno parece
tener sus propias convicciones para
quedarse
no le deseo a nadie que experimente algo
como esto yo tengo 86 años usted me
acomodaría a esta edad en su casa no en
mi calle soy el único que no se ha ido
todas las casas Están o destruidas o
dañadas
las autoridades con la ayuda de los
voluntarios llevan realizando
evacuaciones durante meses muchos
deciden irse Solo cuando su casa es
alcanzada por un proyectil Entonces si
toman la decisión la mayoría son
personas mayores que vivieron Durante
los tiempos de la unión soviética su
supervivencia depende de centros como
estos a los que llegan arriesgando sus
vidas aquí buscan el abrigo la luz el
agua y el alimento que no tienen en sus
casas este lugar es importante para
nosotros no tenemos agua electricidad en
la casa vivimos gracias a estos centros
sin este lugar moriríamos de hambre Dime
qué pasa los días en este otro centro
ubicado en un sótano en uno de los
sectores más atacados por las fuerzas
rusas dice que se han quedado para
acompañar a su abuela mi vida empieza
con la idea de encontrar la manera
segura de llegar hasta aquí rápido y
luego en la tarde tenemos que pensar en
cómo regresar al apartamento su sueño
como el del resto es que se silencian
Los cañones que apuntan sobre vacuno